y luego de que se anunciara la retirada
de las tropas de eeuu en afganistán esta
era una situación previsible y bueno
mira yo creo que es importante saber que
la razón que estamos teniendo esta
conversación es por una decisión que
tomó el presidente de eeuu en el 14 de
abril de retirar todas las tropas de
eeuu en afganistán
ellos respeto mucho al presidente bailo
conozco he trabajado con él desde los
años 80 es un buen hombre pero este en
este caso fue un error estratégico de
una orden muy grande y lo hemos visto
sino usted y yo no estuviéramos hablando
y ha sido una decisión precipitada no
había ninguna razón porque teníamos que
sacar nuestras tropas y la de optar
teníamos una presencia militar muy
pequeña varios millares de soldados y un
contingente aéreo pequeño pero era muy
eficaz
era un apoyo al margen pero estratégico
para las fuerzas armadas de afganistán
que estaban haciendo el 95 por ciento de
la lucha y 99 por ciento de las muertes
cuando yo era embajador tanto para el
presidente obama como el presidente de
cra
era así los afganos estaban peleando
pero necesitaban el apoyo aéreo en
ciertos momentos y de fuerzas especiales
pero no al margen
pero todo ha cambiado los dejamos
realmente solos
y particularmente la cobertura aérea las
fuerzas afganas fueron entrenadas por
estados unidos y votar para luchar con
aire igual que nuestras tropas usar
tropas de eeuu estuvieran en afganistán
sin cobertura aérea no tuvieran una
situación bastante complicada
señor llorens esto tiene que ver con que
los talibanes hayan logrado avanzar tan
rápida y efectivamente capturar 12 de
las 34 capitales del país
y mira dónde ese verdadero estrellas
gran vida lo ha consumido afganistán a
mí no me sorprende y yo le dije a la
prensa esto en mayo en junio pudiera
haber sido un mes más dos meses más que
uno pudiera haber dicho que que los
talibanes pudieran haber capturado
tantas capitales de las provincias
tenemos 13 o 14 de las 34 yo hubiera
dicho que para octubre estamos en agosto
pero era inevitable porque otra vez
ellos estaban cubriendo mucho terreno
así que el ejército estaba expandido en
un territorio grande afganistán es del
tamaño del estado de tejas estaban
tratando de cubrir todos los pueblitos
las ciudades áreas rurales y los
talibanes estaban en una situación donde
podían concentrar fuerzas y atacar los
pedazos por pedazos y eso es lo que han
hecho han hecho empezaron por el norte y
por el sur y han tenido mucho éxito pero
otra vez
recuerda tuvimos una estabilidad militar
en un era un juego entablado en
afganistán con el pequeño contingente de
eeuu y de otan es
imposible que los talibanes tuvieran una
victoria estratégica es imposible
nosotros no le podíamos ganar a ellos
andrés es ahora verdad pero no nos
podían ganar y ahí es donde estaba el
juego porque un acuerdo negociado entre
los talibanes y el gobierno y kabul sólo
se podía lograr sin ambos lados
entendían que no podían llegar a una
victoria militar claro el señor llorens
en la comunidad internacional expresado
gran preocupación por lo que está
sucediendo en afganistán muy brevemente
podríamos ver nuevamente una
intervención extranjera en este país
yo no lo veo andrés yo creo que ya el
presidente en byn ha tomado su decisión
es un tema que él cree que ha tomado la
decisión correcta de terminar estas
guerras que nunca terminan para eeuu así
que yo no veo ninguna probabilidad y yo
creo que es difícil salvar la situación
en afganistán ahora lo que hemos tratado
de ayudar al gobierno manteniendo ayuda
económica
y a suministro militar balas rifles y
eso sería un compromiso en eso y cierto
bombardeo de bases eeuu en el golfo en
los países del golf